Well, hello, listener. Listen, I've been drawing an animated version of myself because I'm going to, I want to do a cartoon. Anyway, so here, this little Jakey Bates is over here. Hi, it's really great to see you, Jason. Wait, little Jakey, are you drinking? It's pretty early. No, no, this is water. Here, take a little water. Well, that's definitely not water. But anyway, sit down or lay down, rather, for you. Probably lay down would be better. And here comes a fresh new episode. Smart. Smart.
听着，听着，我一直在画一个动画版的自己，因为我打算，我想做一个动画片。总之，这里，这个小杰基·贝茨就在这儿。嗨，很高兴见到你，杰森。等等，小杰基，你在喝酒吗？这还挺早的。不，不，这是水。来，喝点水。好吧，那绝对不是水。不过总之，请坐，或者说躺下，对你来说。可能躺下来会更好。全新一集来了。太聪明了。太聪明了。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
太聪明了。太聪明了。太聪明了。太聪明了。太聪明了。太聪明了。太聪明了。太聪明了。
Smart. Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Right? Where is it? Wow.
太聪明了。在哪儿？在哪儿？在哪儿？在哪儿？对吧？在哪儿？哇。
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
哇。哇。哇。哇。哇。哇。哇。哇。
Wow. Is that a movie cigarette? What do you mean? Yeah. It is. I can tell by the way that the cherry's burning. Is it looks so fake. Oh, no, but that's a, that's a clove or like the, the, the, the urbal ones that they give Why? Like this, does this look natural?
哇。那是道具烟吗？什么意思？对。是的。我从烟头燃烧的方式就能看出来。看起来太假了。哦，不，但那是，那是丁香烟，或者是他们发的那种草本烟，为什么？像这样，这看起来自然吗？
What are you blowing out of your mouth? Is that water vapor? Confidence. Oh, God. Somebody's found a new. I like your attitude. I like your attitude with the smoke now. You've got, you see now you've got more attitude, Sean.
你嘴里吹出来的是什么？那是水蒸气？自信。哦，天哪。有人找到了新的。我喜欢你的态度。你现在这种抽烟的态度我很喜欢。你现在，你看你现在更有态度了，肖恩。
Okay, so let me ask you, Will. Yeah. It's cause we had it in Tusk, and now we're arguing last night. I don't, someone just told me to hold it here, but you hold it up here. Am I closer to the top of your, right? Yeah, it just depends.
好吧，那我问你，威尔。对。因为我们在《獠牙》里拍过，然后我们昨晚还在争论。我不知道，有人刚告诉我要把这个拿在这儿，但你拿得比较高。我离你顶端比较近，对吧？对，这得看情况。
I mean, thanks for coming to the expert. This is one of those like talk to the expert sections. Yeah, you just got to, you got to find that kind of like loose, you know what I mean? Yeah, like right in the middle, maybe. But do you want me to do Will's face right now, or you got a little bit of smoke in the eye? I just learned from all those old maubro billboards.
我的意思是，谢谢你来找专家。这就是那种“向专家请教”的环节。对，你得，你得找到那种放松的感觉，你知道吗？对，就像正中间，也许吧。但你现在是想让我做威尔的脸，还是你眼里进了一点烟？我都是从那些老万宝路广告牌上学来的。
Things are complicated. Yeah. Like, man, how am I going to get those steed down there? Yeah, where's the real horses? You know what I mean? Once I wrangle up this cattle, I'll make my way back to the ranch in the meantime. Well, good morning.
事情很复杂。对。比如，天哪，我要怎么把那些马弄到下面去？对，真正的马在哪儿？你知道吗？等我把这些牛赶拢了，我就回牧场去，在此之前。嗯，早安。
Hi, good morning to everybody. Did everybody sleep okay? Yeah, so, but it's 11 30 where you are, right? Sean or 10 30. Yeah, but I got up at two 30 and went back to bed at seven. That's something we learned about you on the tour. You have a halftime show during your sleep. Do you know that like a century ago or longer,
嗨，大家早安。大家都睡得好吗？对，但是你那边现在是11点半，对吧？肖恩，还是10点半。对，但我两点半就起床了，七点又回去睡了。这是我们在巡演中了解到的关于你的一点。你睡眠期间有个中场秀。你知道吗，大约一个世纪前或更久以前，
people used to do that all the time. They'd sleep, they go to bed early and then they'd wake up in the middle of the night and they would kind of cruise around and talk to people and socialize in the middle of the night. You can read about it. It's very, I read some book about it.
人们经常这样做。他们睡觉，早早睡觉，然后半夜醒来，到处转转，在半夜和人聊天、社交。你可以读到关于它的书。这非常，我读过一本关于它的书。
Wait a second, tell me about that. I'm 53 years old and this is the first time you're telling me that a century ago it was common practice to get up in the middle of the night. Everybody across the world, is that your position? I don't know if everybody across the world, but I remember reading this book about Brooklyn and people would get up and it was not uncommon
等一下，跟我讲讲那个。我53岁了，这是你第一次告诉我，一个世纪前，半夜起床是很常见的做法。全世界的人都这样，这是你的立场吗？我不知道是不是全世界的人，但我记得读过一本关于布鲁克林的书，人们会起床，这并不罕见，
for people to get up at sort of midnight and then walk around and socialize for a couple of hours. And our idea of sleep- In Brooklyn, in just that borough. Well, that's what the book was about, but that was something that was not uncommon at the time, according to the author. I felt that, I read this thing a long time ago,
人们在半夜左右起床，然后四处走动，社交几个小时。而我们对睡眠的看法——在布鲁克林，仅仅是在那个区。好吧，书上是这么写的，但根据作者的说法，这在当时并不罕见。我当时觉得，我很久以前读过这个，
like if you can't sleep, just get up. Like because to fight it is worse. Hang on, hang on, let me work this out. You ever tried to punch yourself across the face and knock yourself back out again? You wake up kind of bruised up. Again, that suggests that you knocked yourself out in the first place to go to sleep.
如果你睡不着，就起床。因为对抗它会更糟糕。等等，等等，让我琢磨一下。你有没有试过给自己脸上来一拳，把自己重新打晕过去？你醒来时身上青一块紫一块的。话又说回来，这说明你一开始就是把自己打晕才睡着的。
Well, I mean, this is a book that I'd read on Staten Island and that 100 years ago, this is the book. I mean, obviously you know I'm calling bullshit because you've never read a book. So I just know that, yeah. So I know that that's not... Sean, what's going on with emergency services in Chicago? They seem very quiet right now
我的意思是，这是一本我在斯塔滕岛读过的书，讲的是100年前，就是这本书。我的意思是，显然你知道我在胡扯，因为你根本没读过书。所以我就是知道，对。所以我知道那不是……肖恩，芝加哥的紧急服务部门怎么了？他们现在看起来非常安静，
because usually they're just... Bruined everyone off the street last night. We had a record last night listener that Sean was... Actually, they're talking about dodging the sirens last night. You don't have to explain what emergency services are to Tracy. I mean, surely she understands. She was a cop, remember she was a cop.
因为通常他们只是……昨晚把所有人都赶出了街。昨晚我们有个记录，听众朋友们，肖恩他……其实，他们昨晚在讨论躲避警车。你不需要向特蕾シー解释什么是紧急服务。我的意思是，她当然懂。她以前是个警察，记得吗，她以前是个警察。
Can I just say how great it was having Tracy on the tour when she came to Chicago in Madison? Wasn't it? And she was so much cooler than you let us to believe. You know, I just want to say... I thought you were gonna say the new period. What about the way she came to Chicago just to see what it was gonna be like
我能说有特蕾西加入巡演，当她来到芝加哥和麦迪逊时有多棒吗？是不是？而且她比你让我们想象的要酷得多。你知道，我只想说……我以为你要说大姨妈呢。她来芝加哥看看情况是怎么样的，
so she could decide whether she wanted to be on stage in Madison. I love that. And then we just got her on. And I asked her afterwards and I'm like, how did she feel? She goes, oh, I was a nervous wreck. I go, did you like it? And she goes, I can't remember one thing about it.
这样她就能决定自己是否想在麦迪逊登台演出，这不是很棒吗？我太喜欢了。然后我们就让她上台了。事后我问她，我说她感觉怎么样。她说，哦，我当时紧张得要命。我说，你喜欢吗？她说，我什么都不记得了。
I mean, by the way, she goes like I blacked out. Did you like thousands of people cheering you wildly when you came on? Some people don't like that. I don't know anybody who doesn't like getting cheered. Hey, Jay, are we interrupting? Is it feed time? Well, you know, it's fucking breakfast time.
我的意思是，顺便说一句，她说就像我断片了一样。当你上台时，有成千上万的人为你疯狂欢呼，你喜欢吗？有些人不喜欢那样。我不认识谁是不喜欢被欢呼的。嘿，杰，我们打扰了吗？是喂食时间吗？好吧，你知道，这他妈是吃早餐的时间。
Oh, okay. You know, we're having, this is a real concession we're making for Sean and his fucking theater passion. God. It's... Oh, because we're on his theater schedule. Oh, you guys, come on. It's 8.30 in the morning.
哦，好吧。你知道，我们正在进行，这是我们为了肖恩和他那该死的热爱戏剧的情怀做出的巨大让步。天哪。这是……哦，因为我们得配合他的戏剧时间表。哦，拜托，伙计们。现在是早上8点半。
I don't, I can't... Five, six, seven, eight. It's not magic time. Magic times after 10, 10 a.m., something like that. Well, it's not like those Saturdays for the Ozark schedule, boy. Sometimes early, sometimes late. Sorry about that.
我不行，我不能……五，六，七，八。现在可不是魔法时间。魔法时间是10点之后，上午10点左右，诸如此类。好吧，这可不像欧扎克剧组那些周六的安排，老兄。有时早，有时晚。真是不好意思。
I know, I know. I hope that our guest is on some sort of a central or eastern time and not as... I think our guest is. And our guest is also accustomed to changing schedule, especially performing live, because our guest is no stranger to performing live. In fact, they started out,
我知道，我知道。我希望我们的嘉宾是处于某个中部或东部时间，而不是……我想我们的嘉宾是的。而且我们的嘉宾也习惯了改变时间表，特别是进行现场表演，因为我们的嘉宾对于现场表演并不陌生。事实上，他们刚开始的时候，
they started out making commercials, et cetera, just like a lot of people making some memorable appearances. Oh, I know who it is. I'm kidding. Great, some great shows. I remember a particular episode of the littlest hobo that I will never forget. Are you freestyling right now, Will,
他们刚开始是拍广告之类的，就像很多人一样，有过一些令人难忘的亮相。哦，我知道是谁了。开玩笑的。太棒了，一些很棒的节目。我记得有一集《小流浪者》，我永远不会忘记。你在即兴发挥吗，威尔，
or have you written anything down? I am, I'm freestyling. This person then went on to perform, take his comedy chops over to the UK where his family originated from, and performed comedy and sketch and improv over there, moved it back to Toronto, moved his way right to the main stage on Second City,
还是你写了什么东西下来？我是，我在即兴发挥。这个人后来去表演，把他的喜剧才华带到了他的家族发源地英国，在那里表演喜剧、滑稽短剧和即兴表演，然后搬回了多伦多，一路闯到了第二城剧团的主舞台，
then to Chicago, then to improv, doing Second City there, improv olympics. This person doesn't sound funny at all. Then made a move to Saturday Night Live, where he absolutely blasted onto the scene, made a bunch of incredibly memorable movies over the last 20, 30 years. Mike Myers.
然后去了芝加哥，然后去即兴表演，在第二城剧团表演，即兴奥运会。这个人听起来一点也不好笑。然后去了《周六夜现场》，在那里绝对一炮而红，在过去20、30年里拍了一堆极其令人难忘的电影。麦克·梅尔斯。
Some of the best comedies of all time. It's Mike Myers. Did I get it? He's the only person I know who loves the Toronto May believes as much as I do. It's the incredible, the hilarious, the amazing Mike Myers. Got it. Mike Myers!
一些有史以来最好的喜剧。是麦克·梅尔斯。我猜对了吗？他是我认识的唯一一个像我一样热爱多伦多枫叶队的人。这就是不可思议的、搞笑的、了不起的麦克·梅尔斯。猜对了。麦克·梅尔斯！
I know that's the first time I've ever gotten it. Hello, how are you? Hello. I'm smoking my pen. Hello. Hello. Oh, nice. See, Mike is doing a good job.
我知道这是我第一次猜中。你好，你好吗？你好。我在抽我的电子烟。你好。你好。哦，不错。看，麦克做得很好。
There you go. Did you do that, Mike? Did you see this? Yes, I did. It looks real, right? Mike, were you ever a smoker? No, never. No.
给你。那是你弄的吗，麦克？你看到了吗？是的，我弄的。看起来很真实，对吧？麦克，你以前是个烟民吗？不，从来没有。不。
Yeah. No. I smoked in a tree fort once, and that's where I started. Truly. With a playboy that we found in the woods that was thick. And that's the last time I smoked. Mike, I'm glad that you mentioned that you found some playboys, because I remember I found in Toronto
对。不。我在树屋里抽过一次烟，那就是我开始的地方。真的。和一个我们在树林里找到的很厚的花花公子杂志。那是最后一次我抽烟。麦克，我很高兴你提到你找到了一些花花公子杂志，因为我记得我在多伦多
at a trash can at a bus station, an old penthouse magazine. And I'm like, maybe this is a Canadian thing, just people throwing out their dirty mags. I think it is. It's the great purging that happens every March. You have to purge your porn. Wait, Mike, look at this photo. Look at this photo.
公交车站的垃圾桶里找到过一本旧的阁楼杂志。我就想，也许这是加拿大特有的现象，只是人们在扔掉他们的色情杂志。我想是的。这是每年三月发生的大清洗。你必须清理你的色情刊物。等等，麦克，看这张照片。看这张照片。
Hold on one second. Let me see. Oh, wow. Is that from Kat in the Hat? That's me and you. No, that's before I got well in grace. I met you at Barney's. At Barney's in New York?
等一下。让我看看。哦，哇。那是出自《戴帽子的猫》吗？那是我和你。不，那是我在《威尔和格蕾丝》里状态好之前。我在巴尼百货遇见你的。在纽约的巴尼百货？
No. Yeah, and the parking lot. Mike, were you selling jackets? Isn't that crazy? I was, reasonably priced. High quality. Mike, I'm so thrilled to be talking to you. I met you only the once.
不是。对，在停车场。麦克，你以前是在卖夹克吗？这不是太疯狂了吗？我是，价格合理。高品质。麦克，我很高兴能和你说话。我只见过你一次。
I shook your hand out in front of some screening. And I thought I would meet you again sooner than now. Was hoping, was wishing, but happy, better late than never. I'm such a big fan of yours. Really. Well, thank you likewise. Thank you. Mike, talk a little bit about, as a Canadian, of course,
我在某场试映会外面跟你握过手。我以为我会比现在更早再见到你。我曾希望，曾期盼，不过没关系，总比没有好。我是你的超级粉丝。真的。谢谢你，彼此彼此。谢谢。麦克，能聊聊，作为一个加拿大人，当然，
I always looked up to you as well, because you were a guy from Toronto who went and did it. And did it, not just made great stuff, but made great thing after great thing. It was hilarious. And for me, it was so inspirational. I was like, see, you can get out of Toronto. You can do stuff.
我一直也很崇拜你，因为你是那个从多伦多走出去并做到了这一切的人。而且不仅做到了，不仅做出了伟大的作品，而且是一部接一部地做出伟大的作品。太搞笑了。对我来说，这太鼓舞人心了。我就想，看吧，你可以离开多伦多。你可以干出一番事业。
What was that feeling like when you made it in the US? We know what that being Canadian experience is. You know, it's, you know, being Canadian is, you know, sitting at the border looking south and going, wow, it's a big party. Can I come too? Wow. And it was unbelievable.
当你真正在美国取得成功时，那种感觉是什么样的？我们都知道那种身为加拿年的经历。你知道，你知道，身为加拿大人就是，你知道，坐在边境线往南看，然后说，哇，这真是个大派对。我也能去吗？哇。那真是难以置信。
I still can't believe it. It's very, very gratifying. And, you know, American show business is the best show business in the world. I know that sounds weird, but it's absolutely true. Do you live in the States now or do you live in Toronto? I live in New York. Oh, you do? Oh, great.
我至今仍难以置信。这非常非常令人欣慰。而且，你知道，美国的演艺界是世界上最好的演艺界。我知道这听起来很奇怪，但绝对是事实。你现在住在美国还是住在多伦多？我住在纽约。哦，是吗？哦，太好了。
Yeah. I come in with such specificity with what you do and what your funny was and seem to make no apologies for it. You didn't kind of have, keep one hand behind your back and kind of play it safe at all, you know, to all of our, you know, fortune, you know, you just really kicked the door down and we're really, the characters that you played,
对。你对你所做的事情以及你的搞笑风格有着如此明确的定位，而且似乎对此毫不道歉。你并没有那种留一手、稳扎稳打的心态，你知道的，托你的福，你知道的，你真的是一脚踢开了大门，而且，你扮演的角色，
I can't imagine anybody else ever playing them. And it took a lot of acting talent as well to be as funny as you were. It's just remarkable, truly. It is. I saw the recent Austin Powers commercial that's running now and I'm like, I don't even know what the product is. I was like, oh my God.
我无法想象还有谁能扮演它们。而且要像你一样搞笑，也需要大量的演技。这简直太了不起了，真的。确实如此。我看到了最近正在播出的奥斯汀·鲍尔斯广告，然后我想，我甚至不知道这产品是什么。我就想，哦，天哪。
I was like, oh my God, Mike's back, is that? I think everybody, it's a historical character now. But then even like the small part you did in Tarantino's movie too, it's just, you know, it's never surprising to see you be incredible. Or Bohemian Rhapsody as well. Like you're just, so Mike, let me ask you. So you come out of Toronto, you go and you go to England.
我就想，哦，天哪，麦克回来了，那是？我想每个人，他现在是一个历史人物了。但甚至像你在昆汀电影里的那个小角色，你知道的，看到你表现得如此不可思议，永远都不会让人感到意外。还有《波西米亚狂想曲》也是。所以麦克，让我问你。你从多伦多出来，然后你去了英国。
We talked a little bit about Mike and his alter ego, Tommy Maitland came and did the gong show for two years. Another incredible character. And Mike's only rule was we could never tell anybody that it was Mike. And people were like, who the fuck is this guy, Tommy Maitland?
我们刚才聊了一点关于麦克和他的另一个自我，汤米·梅特兰来主持了两年《贡秀》。另一个不可思议的角色。麦克唯一的规则就是我们绝不能告诉任何人那是麦克。人们当时都在想，这他妈到底是谁，这个汤米·梅特兰？
And he was so in it. It was crazy. It was amazing that the network allowed him to do it. And it was so. Yes, to their credit. To their credit. Was there ever a big announcement about it? Did you guys ever take the victory lap that you deserve
而且他演得太入戏了。太疯狂了。电视网竟然允许他这么做，真是太惊人了。而且确实如此。是的，真得归功于他们。真得归功于他们。这事有过什么大肆的官宣吗？你们有没有进行过你们应得的胜利巡游，
by making a big announcement finally and saying, look what we did? I guess second season, Mike. Yeah, second season we had to because there's a journalistic standards of, is this fake news? So they went along with it until the whole fake news. Aha. Well, that's cool.
最后通过大肆宣布并说，看看我们做了什么？我猜是第二季吧，麦克。对，第二季我们必须得这么做，因为有关于这是不是假新闻的新闻伦理标准。所以他们一直顺着演，直到整个假新闻事件。啊哈。嗯，那挺酷的。
Not controversy, but it came to a head. Like no journalist would go along with it. You know what I mean? Right. Which I understand, but you know, it was fun. I had so much fun doing that. Oh, Mike, you were so, you were so game and he had to get all this prosthetics done every day
倒不是什么争议，而是事情发展到了白热化阶段。就像没有记者会顺着这个演下去，你知道吗？对。我能理解，但这很有趣。我做这件事时开心极了。哦，麦克，你太，你太配合了，而且他每天都得化那些假体妆，
and be in it for hours and then have so much energy as this sort of late middle-aged guy who's trying to drum up the energy to get the audience going. And my favorite was Mike talking to people backstage that he knew, like Fred Armisen coming and talking to Mike and Mike was full Tommy Maitland with Fred. It was so surreal.
还得在里面待上几个小时，然后作为一个半大老头子，还要保持那么大劲头，努力调动观众的情绪。我最喜欢的是麦克在后台和认识的人聊天，比如弗莱德·阿米森来和麦克聊天，麦克在弗莱德面前完全就是汤米·梅特兰附体。这太超现实了。
I mean, it was a different human being. It was crazy. Is there any Richard Dawson baked into it? There's a little Richard Dawson, that sort of mid-Atlantic almost English accent for export. Like real English people don't actually talk that way. Uh-huh. But I'm always obsessed with culture for export.
我的意思是，完全变成了另一个人。太疯狂了。里面有没有融入一点理查德·道森的成分？有一点理查德·道森的影子，那种大西洋中部几乎是出口专用的英国口音。真正的英国人其实不那样说话。嗯哼。但我总是对出口文化的现象很着迷。
Like I think sometimes I talk like a Canadian for export. Right. Just like it's assumed of me or something. So Mike, do you walk around the house and work on new characters or? I do, I have three kids. So, you know, wow. I did this one strange character for my kid Spike
就像我觉得有时候我说话像个出口专用的加拿大人。对。就像这是别人对我的某种设想之类的一样。所以麦克，你在家里走来走去的时候会琢磨新角色吗？会，我有三个孩子。所以，你知道，哇。我为我的孩子斯派克创作了一个奇怪的角色，
who's 10 and he's very socially conscious, you know, which this generation is gonna be fine. You know what I mean? And I was like, I've watched you. I saw you from across the street. And he goes, who are you? My son going along with it. He goes, where do you live?
他10岁，非常有社会意识，你知道的，这一代人以后会没问题的。你知道吗？我就说，我看着你呢。我在街对面看到你了。他就问，你是谁？我儿子还挺配合的。他问，你住哪儿？
I said, I live on this street. And he went, dad, he's homeless. You think homelessness is funny? And I was like, no, I don't. I think it's a tragedy. I wasn't, I just, it's an improv. And that's the first thing that came to my mind. And you guys, you know, it's a real problem here in New York.
我说，我就住这条街上。他接着说，爸爸，他是无家可归的人。你觉得无家可归很有趣吗？我就说，不，我不觉得。我觉得这是一个悲剧。我不是那个意思，我只是，这只是一场即兴表演。那是脑子里第一个冒出来的词。然后你们知道的，这在纽约是个真正的问题。
I got lectured by my 10 year old. And then you should have given them the lecture about yes anding. Yes. And they, it wasn't well received. So Mike, so you, you've done all these amazing, by the way, I've always thought, I can't believe you should have won an Emmy for Tommy Maitland
我被我10岁的儿子给说教了一通。然后你本该跟他讲讲“是的，而且”的即兴原则。是的。而且，这并没有受到好评。所以麦克，你，你做过所有这些了不起的，顺便说一句，我一直觉得，我真不敢相信你应该凭汤米·梅特兰赢得艾美奖，
because it was so above and beyond. Yeah, thank you. Oh man, it was just amazing. I love the gong show as a kid. So for me, it was like, are you kidding? It was tell me when and what to wear, you know? And it just, I loved it was pre-ambition. That's what I love about, you know what I mean?
因为它实在是太超越了。对，谢谢。哦天哪，这简直太棒了。我小时候就特别喜欢《贡秀》。所以对我来说，这就好像，你在开玩笑吧？这就是告诉我什么时候该做什么打扮，你知道吗？我太喜欢那种没有野心的状态了。这就是我所热爱的，你知道吗？
Yeah, yeah. It's just to make people laugh. My company's called No Money Fun Films because that is my favorite thing. And I love comedians that like to be funny. Like Dana Carvey is where I was on tour with him. He's hilarious. So hilarious.
对，对。就是为了逗人笑。我的公司叫“无钱开心电影”，因为那是我最喜欢的事情。我喜欢那些喜欢搞笑的喜剧演员。比如达纳·卡维，我曾和他一起巡演。他太搞笑了。超级搞笑。
And I did movies with him. He's hilarious just for, just to be funny. Do you know what I mean? Yeah. He just, and he does running, running gags, which is my favorite thing too, which is he would do this thing with the Beatles, just talking filthy.
我还跟他一起拍过电影。他搞笑纯粹是因为，为了搞笑。你知道吗？对。而且，他老是抖包袱，这也是我最喜欢的，也就是他会模仿甲壳虫乐队，嘴里净说些下流话。
So it'd be, I'd remember one time. And then it was like, it was George and I, and there was just three buns. And it was just so filthy. And so all he had to do was be on stage with him in these big crowds and under the laugh, he'd go, I remember one time. I'd be like, how do you do that?
所以我记得有一次。然后就说，当时是乔治和我，旁边只有三个圆面包。内容就是这么下流。所以他只要在这些大批观众面前和他一起站在舞台上，在笑声中，他就会说，我记得有一次。我就会想，你怎么能做到那样？
He is literally the most relaxed performer. Yes, yes. And he's a conductor. When he does his stand up, he's just remarkable. But I love running jokes and I love that he is committed to them as well. Mike, do you forgive my ignorance, but do you do stand up?
他简直是世界上最放松的表演者。对，对。而且他就像个乐队指挥。当他进行单口喜剧表演时，他简直太出色了。但我就是喜欢连续不断的笑话，我也喜欢他对这些笑话的执着。麦克，请原谅我的无知，但你做过单口喜剧吗？
Did you start with stand up? Never did stand up. I did it once and I was so ill from it before going out. I like threw up and I don't know how people do that. Did you have a bunch of stuff written out and prepared? Like, had you worked on like a set? No, I thought I could just, I thought I just go up there and I'll just, I'll speak, you know?
你是从单口喜剧开始的吗？从来没做过单口。我做过一次，上台前我难受得要命。我甚至吐了，我不知道人们是怎么做那事的。你当时写好了一大堆东西并准备好了吗？比如，你排练过一套词吗？没有，我以为我可以直接，我以为我只要上台去，然后我就会说，你知道吗？
I'll just, I'll tell him the truth as I see it. It was like, you suck, get off the stage. We hate you. We hate your truth. Sounds horrible. So do you keep in touch with Lorne or check in on SNL or anything like that? Just see what's going on.
我就会把我的真实所见告诉他们。结果就像是，你太烂了，滚下台去。我们讨厌你。我们讨厌你的真心话。听起来太可怕了。那你跟洛恩还有联系吗，或者会去SNL看看什么的？就看看情况怎么样。
I do, yeah. You do? Oh, that's great. I didn't know that. Oh, yeah. Yeah, I didn't know how long those, how long his students, how long he keeps in touch with his kids. I'm very, you know, I'm very grateful to Lorne,
我会的，对。你会吗？哦，那太好了。我不知道。哦，对。对，我不知道那些，他的那些学生，他跟他的“孩子们”保持联系能保持多久。我非常，你知道的，我非常感激洛恩，
gave me my break in TV and my break in movies and he's a Canadian hero and continues to be. And one of the, literally, I don't, I quote Lorne maybe 10 times a day. You know what I mean? Yeah. Just in little things too. It's like, well, you know, being in a car,
给了我在电视界和电影界的突破机会，他是个伟大的加拿大英雄，而且现在也是。而且他真的是，我不知道，我一天大概要引用洛恩的话10次。你知道吗？对。就用在一些小事上。比如，你知道的，在车里，
the audience doesn't mind it. That's where you should put all of your exposition. You know. You know. You know, it's just like little things like that. When you have a special guest, you should have to give them an entrance round, round of applause, you know, build that in.
观众并不介意。你应该把所有的背景交代都放在那里。你知道。你知道。你知道，就类似这样的小事情。当你有一位特邀嘉宾时，你应该让他们伴随着一轮热烈的掌声登场，你知道的，把这个气势做出来。
Yeah, he's got those great. I remember when Amy started on update and he said, it's going to be different because now the audience hears your name. Yes. And I was like, oh yeah, that makes sense. The other one was just when you're in the VIP room, there's a VIP room that ends up being you,
对，他有那些很棒的。我记得艾米刚开始做《周末新闻》时他说，这会很不一样，因为现在观众听到你的名字了。是的。我就想，哦对，这说得通。另一个就是当你在VIP休息室的时候，那个VIP休息室最后里面只有你，
Mick Jagger and the hot water pipes. Oh my God, that sounds so good. And then I was in Cannes for Shrek. And the guy said, miss you, you don't want to be in this room. There's a better room. And I went and it was me, Mick Jagger and the hot water pipes.
米克·贾格尔和暖气水管。哦天哪，听起来太棒了。然后我在戛纳宣传《怪物史瑞克》。那家伙说，迈克，你不想在这个房间里。有更好的房间。然后我去了，里面只有我和米克·贾格尔以及暖气水管。
And I was like, he's right. He's right with that even, you know. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. There's such a specific work routine and rhythm and schedule with SNL that obviously you flourished in. How have you, as you've gotten older,
我就想，他是对的。他甚至在这点上也是对的。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。SNL有一种非常独特的工作常规、节奏和时间表，你显然在那里大放异彩。随着你年龄的增长，
even more talented, more specific with what you do and capable of even so many other things, how have you noticed your change in what you like to do as far as rhythm goes and work routine? And do you miss the rush, rush, rush of that? Or do you prefer, yeah. I miss the rush, rush, rush.
变得更有才华、对自己做的事情更专注、并且能够胜任更多其他事情，你如何注意到自己对喜欢做的事情在节奏和工作常规方面发生了什么变化？你怀念那种匆忙、匆忙、再匆忙的节奏吗？还是你更倾向于，是的。我怀念那种匆忙、匆忙、再匆忙的节奏。
You know, again, another lornism. It's not the best show that goes on in 1130. It's the best show that's ready to go on at 1130. That's hilarious. It offers you a tremendous freedom from choice. You know what I mean? Right. And you have to make specific choices immediately.
你知道的，又是洛恩的一句名言。最好的节目不是11点30分播出的那个。而是11点30分准备好播出的那个。太搞笑了。这为你从选择中解放出来提供了巨大的自由。你知道吗？对。而且你必须立刻做出具体的选择。
Which I did that on Second City as well. And in the London, I think the greatest training I had in a weird way was the London Cabaret Circuit, which is if they loved you, they loved you. You had to be fresh. That's the other thing too. You had to do comedy where comedy hadn't existed before or you would get either booed off the stage
我在第二城剧团时也是这么做的。在伦敦，我觉得我受过最好的训练，说来奇怪，是伦敦的滑稽喜剧巡演圈，也就是说如果他们喜欢你，他们就会喜欢你。你必须保持新鲜感。这也是另一回事。你必须在以前没有喜剧存在的地方表演喜剧，否则要么你会被嘘下台，
or often hummed off the stage. Well, one time I was complimented off the stage, which is, you're doing a good job, Mike. You know, I don't even know my name. What does that mean doing comedy in a space that hasn't been done before? It's the topics of British comedy are very, very wide. Things that are, like there was a time
或者经常是被哄下台。嗯，有一次我是在赞美声中下台的，那就是，你干得不错，麦克。你知道，我甚至都不知道我的名字。在以前没有演过喜剧的空间里表演喜剧是什么意思？英国喜剧的话题非常非常广泛。那些事情，比如曾几何时，
when it was always mother-in-law jokes, you know what I'm saying? And that was a very narrow subject matter to do comedy. In England, they require that you, for example, there was a comedy troupe called The Entire Population of China, this double act, these two guys. And they did a sitcom in Chaucerian English. So it had all the rhythm with a laugh track.
总是丈母娘笑话，你知道我在说什么吗？那是一个非常狭窄的喜剧题材。在英国，他们要求你，例如，有一个喜剧剧团叫“中国总人口”，这个双人组合，这两个家伙。他们用乔叟时期的英语表演情景喜剧。所以它带有带笑声音轨的所有节奏。
Oh my God. So with the router, like, and this is a room above a pub in Camden and people are like, yes, new, different. Gotcha. Well, and Mike, what's due to the enjoyment of wanting to develop characters? Like when you were younger, like, was it a person?
哦，天哪。所以配上那个，就像，这是坎顿一家酒吧上面的房间，人们就会觉得，哇，新鲜，不同。明白了。那么麦克，开发角色的乐趣从何而来？比如当你年轻的时候，比如，是一个人吗？
Was it a thing? Where you're like, oh, I can do these voices. I didn't even know I could do voices. Well, I think, you know, growing up in Canada, it is, you're an observer nation, you know what I mean? Yeah, that's interesting. And Canada is not really a melting pot. It's more of a salad bowl, you know, when you come over,
是一件事吗？当时你会觉得，哦，我可以模仿这些声音。我甚至不知道自己会模仿声音。嗯，我想，你知道，在加拿大长大，这是一种观察者的国家，你知道吗？对，这很有意思。而且加拿大并不是一个真正的熔炉。它更像是一个大拼盘，你知道的，当你来到这里，
it's just a different thing. And so cultures and how people talk is something, and I think SCTV said to me that it was possible to come from Toronto and do what I do. Gilda Radner played my mom in a TV commercial when I was nine. Wow, wow. And I watched her on Saturday Night Live
那是完全不同的东西。所以各种文化以及人们说话的方式是一回事，而且我认为SCTV告诉我，从多伦多出来并做我所做的事情是可能的。吉尔达·拉德纳在我九岁时在一个电视广告里演过我妈妈。哇，哇。我在《周六夜现场》上看了她的表演，
and I turned to my family and said, that's what I'm gonna do for, I'm gonna do that. I'm gonna be on that show. Yeah, all right. And I think of all of the original cast, I think I relate more to Gilda Radner than Belushi or Akroyd, who I worshiped Dan Akroyd, but I think I was more like Gilda Radner, really.
我转向家人说，这就是我要做的，我要去那儿。我要上那个节目。是的，好吧。而且我认为在所有原班人马中，我觉得自己比贝尔希或艾克罗伊德更像吉尔达·拉德纳，虽然我崇拜丹·艾克罗伊德，但我真的觉得自己更像吉尔达·拉德纳。
Yeah, yeah. Peter Sellers was a huge influence. My dad, you know, he's English him. You know, I had two Liverpool parents and they were like, Wow. My dad's biggest compliment was, oh, I wish he was English. You know. You know, Mike, it's funny, I said,
对，对。彼得·塞勒斯影响非常大。我爸爸，你知道，他是英国人。你知道，我有两个利物浦父母，他们当时就想，哇。我爸爸给出的最高赞誉就是，哦，我希望他是英国人。你知道。你知道，迈克，这很有趣，我说，
I remember talking to, you know, our mutual friend, Rob Cohen, great writer, funny guy, amazing. And he actually made this documentary as you know, about what it means to be, why Canadians are funnier, why there are seemingly so many Canadian comedic actors and comedians, et cetera. And I always said that it felt like, and as a Canadian, obviously referenced that it,
我记得和我们的共同好友罗布·科恩聊过，他是个伟大的作家，风趣幽默，非常了不起。如你所知，他实际上拍过一部纪录片，探讨为什么加拿大人更有趣，为什么似乎有那么多加拿大喜剧演员和笑星等等。我一直觉得，作为加拿大人，我显然也提到过这一点，它...
it's almost like we were born up against the glass, right? Like it's like at the rink and you're just looking in, we're not in the game yet, we're just kind of there. And we have the luxury of kind of, we don't necessarily have any skin in the game, we can just observe and comment on it. Does that ring true to you? 100%, you know, Martin Short used to say,
这就好像我们生来就被挡在玻璃墙外，对吧？就像在溜冰场里，你只能往里看，我们还没真正参与到比赛中，只是站在一旁。我们有一种奢侈，就是我们不必非得承担什么风险，我们只需观察和评论。这听起来对吗？百分之百，你知道的，马丁·肖特以前常说，
you know, when Americans are watching TV, they're watching TV, but when Canadians are watching TV, we're watching American TV. Yeah. There is just a slight separation. That's so funny. And it's a weird, like, it's a party happening upstairs that you wish you were invited to, you know what I mean?
你知道的，美国人在看电视的时候，他们就是在看电视；但加拿大人在看电视时，我们看的是美国电视。是的，只是有那么一点点微妙的区别。太好笑了。这就好比楼上正在开派对，而你多希望自己能被邀请去参加，你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah. But you also have that kind of like, those people are crazy upstairs, you know? Get a load of them. Well, Mike, I don't know if you remember, I had this experience when I moved to New York many moons ago, and I would come back to Toronto and people would say, oh, Willie, you sound, you're American now, eh?
是的。但你也会有一种“楼上那些人疯了，你懂吧？瞧他们那样”的感觉。嗯，迈克，我不知道你记不记得，很多月前我搬到纽约时也有过这种经历，每当我回到多伦多，人们就会说，哦，威利，听起来你现在像个美国人了，是吧？
You're down there, you're American. Like as if I had done something wrong. You know, I'm like, what? It's so unfair and not true, by the way, you know, because there's nobody more Canadian than a Canadian who no longer lives in Canada. Yeah, yeah. You get super Canadian when you move down here.
你身在那边，你是个美国人。就好像我做错了什么似的。你知道的，当时我就想，什么？这太不公平了，而且顺便说一句，这也不是真的，你知道的，因为没有人比一个不再住在加拿大的加拿大人更具加拿大特色了。是的，是的。当你搬到这里来时，你会变得超级加拿大。
It's that guy, there was that, the devil's dictionary, that guy Englishman who wrote it, and he had the description of a kilt was a traditional Scottish garb worn by Americans in Scotland and Scots in America. Yes, that's right, exactly. It's a similar thing. So anyway, so you moved in, you go to Chicago,
就是那个家伙，有那个，魔鬼辞典，那个英国人写的，他对苏格兰短裙的描述是：美国人在苏格兰以及苏格兰人在美国时穿的传统苏格兰服饰。对，没错，就是这样。这也是类似的情况。所以无论如何，你搬进去了，你去了芝加哥，
but how many of those characters that you ended up, you know, iconic characters you did on SNL, any of them had you been working on them on Second City? Were they characters that had developed, yeah? Most of the characters I had done at Second City and had done on Canadian TV. I had done Dieter on a show called It's Only Rock and Roll, and I'd done Wayne, I had a thing called Wayne's Power Minute
但是你最后创作的那些标志性角色，比如你在SNL上表演的那些，其中有多少你在第二城剧团时就已经在创作了？它们是已经发展成型的角色吗？我在第二城剧团和加拿大电视节目上做过大多数角色。我曾在《这只是摇滚乐》节目中扮演过迪特，我还扮演过韦恩，我有一个叫《韦恩权力一分钟》的节目
on It's Only Rock and Roll on CBC, on Canadian TV. No way! Power Minute. It's Wayne's Power Minute in the Shaggan Wagon. And it's a... That was my handle in high school, was Power Minute. Shaggan Wagon. Power Minute.
欢迎收听CBC的《这只是摇滚乐》，在加拿大电视台上。不会吧！权力一分钟。这是韦恩在“泡妞车”里的权力一分钟。而且这是一个……我高中时的代号就是权力一分钟。泡妞车。权力一分钟。
Yeah, I don't think it was a compliment, I'm still trying to figure out what it was. Yeah, no, it's 18 seconds of pleasure in the lifetime of responsibility, right? Yeah. So you do, by the way, I mean, Wayne's World, again, as a, I just, that was such a win that, you first started doing that sketch on SNL,
是啊，我觉得那不是什么夸奖，我到现在还在琢磨那到底算什么。对，没错，这就是在一生责任中的18秒快感，对吧？对。所以顺便问一下，我是说，《韦恩的世界》这部电影，再次作为——我只是觉得那真是一次巨大的成功，你最初开始在《周六夜现场》表演那个小品的时候，
it just blew me away, just hilarious. We would quote it, still to this day, of course, how many iconic things came out of it, not, shwing, things that are still part of the vernacular. Do you ever hear that stuff just sort of, like out of your, you know, in your peripheral and just go like, holy shit, I came up with that. Every character, though, like what about behave?
这真的震撼到我了，太搞笑了。我们当时会引用它，直到今天依然会，当然了，里面诞生了多少标志性的梗啊，不，shwing，那些至今仍是日常用语的东西。你有没有听到过那些东西，就像在你的边缘，你知道的，在你的周围，然后感叹，天哪，那是我想出来的。不过每个角色都是如此，比如说behave呢？
Oh yeah, I wasn't even getting to that yet, but yeah. Exactly, there's so much. It's very gratifying, it is, it's unbelievable. You know, like, you know, my parents, my dad sold encyclopedism, my mom worked in the office of a factory that made aerosol can products. So it's not like I'm to the manner born and go, wow, see, my dad used to handle this, you know.
哦，是的，我还没讲到那儿呢，不过确实。没错，内容太多了。这真的很有成就感，太不可思议了。你知道，比如，我父母，我爸爸以前卖百科全书，我妈妈在一家生产气雾罐产品的工厂办公室工作。所以并不是说我生来就自带光环，觉得，哇，你看，我爸以前就处理过这些，你知道的。
So it's all kind of, it's just being unbelievable. I can't believe it. Did your parents fully understand and grasp what a home run your career is and has been? Well, strangely enough, my father had gotten Alzheimer's by the time I'd become successful, which is one of those ironies. The person who would have most delighted
所以这一切都，简直让人难以置信。我简直不敢相信。你的父母是否完全理解并明白你的职业生涯取得的巨大成功？说来也奇怪，等我成功的时候，我父亲已经患上了老年痴呆症，这也是命运的讽刺之一。最为此感到高兴的那个人
in seeing it was, you know, it's a very tough disease Alzheimer's because it's people's personality leave their bodies and so you can't quite have a funeral. And, you know, I think it was once described as the long goodbye, you know? Yeah, for sure, for sure. So your dad never got to see that,
因为阿尔茨海默病确实是一种非常难缠的疾病，你知道的，它会让一个人的性格从肉体中抽离，所以你很难举行一场真正的葬礼。而且，你知道的，它曾经被形容为漫长的告别，不是吗？是的，确实如此，确实如此。所以你父亲从未能看到这一切，
your mom did get to enjoy some of your success? She did and she didn't. She's like, oh, I saw Wainswold. Yeah, what'd you think? Oh, that Dana Carvey's very good, isn't he? Oh, he's just got it, he's just slick, you know? But Americans are, aren't they? They're very slick.
你妈妈确实分享到了一些你的成功喜悦吗？她既分享到了，又好像没有。她会说，哦，我看了温斯沃尔德（Wainswold）。是吗，你觉得怎么样？哦，那个达纳·卡维（Dana Carvey）真不错，是吧？哦，他就是有那一套，就是很圆滑，你知道吗？但美国人就是那样，不是吗？他们非常圆滑。
I've used the other guy in the hat. Yes, don't care for him much. Yeah, Mike, I think that's like English, like my mom, a Canadian, but also a, you know, far back sort of English and Scottish and Irish descent and similar thing, which is, you know, anything. She's smartless, listen, my friends really love smartless. Oh, yeah, thanks, what did you think?
我用过那个戴帽子的家伙。是的，不太喜欢他。是的，麦克，我认为这就像英语一样，就像我妈妈一样，她是个加拿大人，但也具有，你知道的，远祖的那种英格兰、苏格兰和爱尔兰血统，情况也类似，你知道的，随便什么。她很聪明，听着，我的朋友们真的很喜欢SmartLess。哦，是的，谢谢，你觉得怎么样？
Well, they liked it. Okay, you know. Then you find out that she's insufferable to others, you know? Yes, yes. My son made it. Yeah, you know what I loved, Mike? I loved Supermanch. I loved that talk.
嗯，他们挺喜欢的。好吧，你知道的。然后你发现她对别人来说很难相处，对吧？是的，是的。我儿子做的。是啊，迈克，你知道我最喜欢什么吗？我喜欢《超人》，我喜欢那场谈话。
Oh, thank you so much. Yeah, I loved it so much and... It was a documentary for Tracy, it was a documentary that Mike directed. Yeah, on the legendary manager, Shep Gordon, Alice Cooper's manager. Yeah, so cool. I knew nothing about him, actually, and it was so fascinating.
哦，非常感谢。是的，我太喜欢了……这是一部关于特雷西的纪录片，由迈克执导。是的，关于传奇经纪人谢普·戈登，也就是爱丽丝·库珀的经纪人。是的，太酷了。其实我之前对一无所知，真的非常引人入胜。
And did you, was that a pleasurable experience for you? Would you do it again? I would love to do it again. It was a very pleasurable experience. Shep Gordon is one of the nicest human beings in the world, and I thought, what do you give the man who has everything? And I thought, I'll give him the microphone. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
而你，这对你来说是一次愉快的经历吗？你还会再做一次吗？我很乐意再做一次。这是一次非常愉快的经历。谢p·戈登是世界上最好的人之一，我想，你送什么给拥有一切的人呢？我想，我把麦克风送给他。对，对，对。
It's just, I just wanted to... We talked about Lauren, Shep Gordon is very much like Lauren. His art form can only be seen from space, you know what I mean, which is he builds careers in that way. It's almost like a Cristo of building different people's careers. And that's his milieu, his art form.
就是，我只是想... 我们谈过劳伦，谢普·戈登非常像劳伦。他的艺术形式只有从太空才能看到，你知道我的意思吗，也就是说他是用那种方式塑造职业生涯的。这简直就像是把不同人的职业生涯塑造成克里斯托的作品一样。这就是他的环境，他的艺术形式。
Would you direct another documentary, or is there something you were interested in? I would, yeah. Yeah, I've always loved documentaries. I thought I was going to be a documentary filmmaker. Oh, wow. I got hired for Second City and accepted to York University Film on the same day.
你会再执导一部纪录片吗，还是有什么你感兴趣的题材？我会的，是的。是的，我一直很喜欢纪录片。我曾以为自己会成为一名纪录片导演。哦，哇。我同一天被Second City录用并被约克大学电影专业录取。
Oh, wow. And I thought, oh, I'll do Second City for a while, and then go over and study film, and then... Are you, is that something, do you have the time to pursue that at all right now? What fills most of your days? What are you enjoying pursuing? Well, I have a six-part comedy series coming out
哦，哇。我当时想，哦，我先去演一段时间的第二城喜剧剧团，然后再去学习电影，然后……你现在还有时间去追求那个吗？你大部分时间都在忙什么？你喜欢追求什么？嗯，我有一部六集的喜剧系列剧即将上映
in May called The Pentaverate on Netflix. Okay. And I've been doing that for the last two years. Of course, we got hit with COVID right in the middle of it, but it's done now, it's coming out in May. And the premise of it is, is what if five people actually did run the world, but what if they were nice?
五月份在Netflix上线的《五人帮》。好的。过去两年我一直在忙这个。当然，我们在拍摄中途遭遇了新冠疫情，但现在已经完成了，五月份就会播出。它的前提是，如果真的有五个人在统治世界，但如果他们都是好人呢？
Oh, wow. So I wanted to get to The Pentaverate. So this is a show where you play, I think six or seven characters? Seven characters, yeah. Which is insane. You're a masochist. That's a pretty tall order, yeah, you're a masochist.
噢，哇。所以我想谈谈《五人秘密组织》。所以这是一个你饰演，我想有六七个角色的剧？七个角色，是的。这太疯狂了。你是个受虐狂。这真是个艰巨的任务，是的，你是个受虐狂。
Well, looking back, I do see the masochistic nature of that choice. I didn't at the time, of course, but... Did you write this as well or produce it or direct it? I didn't direct it. We have a great director named Tim Kirkby, who's this British genius who directed it. Yeah.
好吧，回想起来，我确实看到了那个选择带有受虐狂的性质。当时我当然没觉得，不过……这个也是你写的、制作的还是导演的？我没有导演。我们有一个非常棒的导演叫蒂姆·柯克比，他是个英国天才，执导了这部作品。是的。
Was able to keep all the seven characters and all the stories all together. And it's, I wanted to do something very cinematic. That's the other thing too. Yeah. So it's closer to, it's kind of if the Da Vinci Code and the prisoner had a baby. And it kind of deals with conspiracy theory.
能够把所有的七个角色和所有的故事都融为一体。而且，我想做一些非常具有电影感的东西。这也是另一回事。对。所以它更接近于，有点像是《达芬奇密码》和《囚徒》生了个孩子。它有点涉及阴谋论。
And basically the need we have right now to have the people trust the experts and the experts serve the people. That's kind of where we're at. And I just, the insanity of what's going on with January 6th and what's going on, this is how I thought I could respond to it. So it's a comment on misinformation
基本上，我们现在需要的是人们信任专家，而专家服务于人民。这就是我们目前所处的状况。我只是觉得，关于×月×日事件以及发生的事情的疯狂状态，这就是我认为我可以应对它的方式。所以这是对谬误信息的一种评论
and disinformation. That's great. Yeah. Is that important to you? I mean, obviously it is. I mean, to be able to speak up and to, there's always that sort of thing of like, hey, use your platform to do the right thing.
还有虚假信息。太棒了。是的。这对你重要吗？我的意思是，显然很重要。我的意思是，能够大声说出来，而且总是有那种感觉，比如，嘿，利用你的平台做正确的事。
And you've chosen to do it in a way that you know, which is to make, to kind of send it up and do it through comedy. Has that always been something that you've wanted to do? Yes. Definitely. I think that the highest aspiration for me would be something like Dr. Strangelove.
而你选择了一种你知道的方式，也就是通过喜剧来讽刺和表达。这一直是你想要做的事情吗？是的。绝对是。我觉得对我来说最高的追求大概就是像《奇爱博士》那样的作品。
That would be the highest aspiration. To me, that is the near perfect comedy, which is kind of like how I feel like Flintstone vitamins. Kids are eating Barney and Dino. They don't need to know what's good for them. You know what I mean? I think that's kind of the best delivery system of ridicule.
那将是最高的追求。对我来说，那是近乎完美的喜剧，就像我看到那种儿童维生素一样。小孩子们在看巴尼和小恐龙。他们不需要知道这东西对他们有什么好处。你知道我的意思吗？我觉得那是最好的嘲讽传递方式。
Right. Adam McKay is doing a good job of that too, I think with the satires that he's making about these important issues. And very, very entertaining, which I think is the key, you know? Yeah, for sure. Mike, talk a little bit about,
对。亚当·麦凯在这方面也做得很好，我觉得他拍的那些关于重要议题的讽刺作品也是如此。而且非常非常有观赏性，我觉得这才是关键，你知道吗？是的，确实如此。迈克，跟我们聊聊，
so you made three Austin Powers movies. You kind of, I think you took a little bit of a break right before you did those movies from acting for like two years. You hadn't done anything. And then all of a sudden, Austin Powers comes on the scene. And it absolutely just, it was a smash success. And what was that experience like?
你拍了三部《王牌大贱谍》。在拍这些电影之前，我想你大概停演了两年左右。你什么都没做。然后突然之间，《王牌大贱谍》就横空出世了。它绝对是一部轰动之作。那段经历是怎样的？
Did you know that it was going to have the impact it did? No, I didn't. I thought you'd have to have grown up in my house to get the movie, to be honest. It was every movie that I loved, the James Bond, the Matt Helm movies, all the Spice Booths. It's actually a spoof of a Spice Booth, really,
你当时知道它会产生那么大的影响力吗？不，我不知道。说实话，我觉得你得是在我家那种环境长大才能看懂这部电影。它包含了所有我热爱的电影，詹姆斯·邦德、马特·海尔姆电影，所有的间谍恶搞片。其实它是一部对间谍片的恶搞，
truthfully, more than it's a James Bond parody. And I wanted to make my own, you know, to talk about Spaghetti Westerns. I wanted to make my own knockoff James Bond thing. And with the assumption that it had always existed in British culture, and now they're making the movie version of it. And in hindsight, it's quite resherché.
说实话，与其说它是对詹姆斯·邦德的恶搞，不如说它更多是对间谍片本身的恶搞。我想拍一部属于我自己的——就像意大利西部片那样。我想拍一部属于我自己的山寨版詹姆斯·邦德电影。假定它在英国文化中一直存在，现在他们正在把这个题材拍成电影。事后看来，这其实非常冷门。
You know, it's a very specific offering. I didn't think it was. And I am as surprised as anybody that it impacted mainstream culture at all. I wanted to make almost an indie comedy. Right. And I didn't know that necessarily it would have any currency beyond people
你知道的，这是一个非常小众的作品。我当时并不觉得。而且对于它竟然对主流文化产生了影响，我和其他人一样感到惊讶。我本来只想拍一部独立喜剧。对。而且我也不知道它除了那些懂得这个梗的人之外，
that knew that idiom, you know? Well, beyond it being undeniably funny, I think if people took it like I did, your commitment, as I said earlier, to your character, to your tone of comedy is so infectious that you have no choice but to enjoy it because you are enjoying it so much. You have so much commitment to it.
是否还会有什么影响力。嗯，除了它无可否认的好笑之外，我觉得如果人们和我一样能体会到的话，就像我刚才说的，你对角色的投入、对喜剧基调的坚持是如此具有感染力，以至于你别无选择，只能去享受它，因为你乐在其中。你对它投入了太多的心血。
And it's just, it's that helpful tether, that leash that you're providing to the audience. Like, I've jumped in with two feet, come on in with me. Yeah, I think a big hallmark of all your characters is how committed you have been. And as Jason pointed out, it takes a great deal of acting. And you never break, even though you have fun with all those characters,
这就好像是提供给观众的一根救命绳索，一条牵引绳。就像是：我已经双脚跳进去了，快跟我一起来吧。是的，我觉得你所有角色的一大标志就是你的全情投入。正如杰森所指出的，这需要大量的演技。而且你从来不会出戏，尽管你对所有这些角色都乐在其中，
you are so thoroughly that person in that moment. And there is that kind of other side, I'm not asking to call anybody out, but there is that kind of comedy, which is much more a comment on characters, which to me feels like, anytime people talk about deconstructing, I'm like, yeah, well, go ahead and construct first.
但在那一刻，你就是那个彻彻底底的人。还有另一种喜剧，我不是想针对谁，但有些喜剧更多是对角色的评判，对我来说，每当人们谈论解构时，我就会想，好吧，先去构建再说吧。
And then feel free to deconstruct, but it's so easy to do that. And you don't ever do that. You don't comment on it, you just are it. Is that something that you ever think about? I do, I actually, I paint a little bit, and I found I can't paint anybody that I don't have positive affections for, you know what I mean?
然后再去谈解构，但这样做实在是太容易了。而你从不那样做。你不对角色评判，你就是角色本身。你曾经想过这个问题吗？我确实想过，其实，我偶尔画画，我发现我无法画任何我没有产生好感的人，你知道我的意思吗？
So I have paintings of, I painted Shep in like 15 minutes, and it's like one of my better paintings, and you know what I mean? I can't judge the people I'm doing, you know what I mean? I have to find where, I had lunch with Mike Nichols, it was one of the greatest lunches of my life. Lauren set it up because he knew I loved Mike Nichols so much.
所以我画过一些画，我大概用15分钟画了谢普，那成了我比较好的画作之一，你知道我的意思吗？我无法去评判我所塑造的人物，你知道吗？我必须去寻找——我和迈克·尼科尔斯吃过午餐，那是生平最棒的午餐之一。洛恩安排的，因为他知道我非常崇拜迈克·尼科尔斯。
And I said, what's your number one direction? Like, what do you find yourself going to? Cause I was like, this is my chance to get some wisdom. He said, that's a good question. He said, it's, I usually say, I say to the actor, look at the character and go, I am like that when. So even if you're a murderer, you can do, I am like that when I kill somebody's good evening
我问他：“你给演员的第一指导原则是什么？比如说，你发现自己最常强调的是什么？”因为我想：“这是我讨教智慧的机会。”他说：“这是个好问题。他说，通常我会对演员说：‘看着那个角色，然后说：我什么时候也会这样。’所以，即使你是一个杀手，你也可以说：‘当我带着坏心情去杀人的时候，我也会这样，’或者你知道我的意思吗？”所以他们的连接方式就是不去评判，而是去寻找——
with a bad mood, or you know what I mean? So that's how they connect, is to not judge, but to find the. Find the part of you that is closest to that character. So you're not acting, you're just, you're amplifying a part of yourself almost. And he also said, just remember, it's not actors talking, it's actors thinking. You're having thoughts that then have to come out in words.
寻找你自己身上最接近那个角色的那一部分。所以你不是在表演，你只是在放大你自己的一部分。他还说：“记住，这不是演员在说话，这是演员在思考。你的脑海中先有了想法，然后这些想法才变成了台词。”
Thoughts lead to emotions. It was an unbelievable masterclass of a lunch that I had with him. Yeah, we'll be right back. All right, back to the show. Mike, were there ever any characters you wanted to see realized on the big screen that you never got a chance to or is still not coming?
想法会带来情感。那真是一场令人难以置信的大师级午餐。是的，我们马上回来。好的，回到节目中。迈克，有没有哪个角色是你一直想在电影大银幕上实现，但却从来没有机会，或者至今还没实现的？
I think Dieter, I think I could still do Dieter. I wanted to do that. I wanted to do, you know, the other thing is through everything I do has a musical connection. So for me, Dieter would be, in essence, it would be my craft work movie. Wayne's World was my heavy metal movie, you know.
我觉得迪特，我觉得我还是能演迪特。我很想演那个。我还想拍——你知道的，另一方面，我做的所有事情都有音乐的联系。所以对我来说，迪特本质上会成为我的发电厂乐队（Kraftwerk）电影。《反斗智多星》是我的重金属电影，你知道的。
Austin Powers was my bird back rack movie, you know. All right. So that's a big influence on what I do as well. What is that musical background? Did you play a bunch of music when you were a kid? No, but it was big in my house, you know what I mean? I was raised by, you know, two culture vultures. And then I was raised by two brothers who were,
《王牌大贱谍》是我的伯特·巴卡拉克电影，你知道的。好的。所以这也是对我所做的事情的一个巨大影响。你的音乐背景是什么？你小时候玩过很多音乐吗？不，但音乐在我家里非常重要，你知道我的意思吗？我是在两个文化爱好者抚养下长大的。后来我又和两个兄弟一起成长，
we just inhaled culture. We just loved stuff. We loved movies. And Canada's a great place to grow up watching movies, especially Toronto. We had all these fantastic second run theaters and they were all connected. So you get one pass and you could go to the Bloor Cinema,
我们简直就像在狂热地吸收文化。我们就是喜欢各种东西。我们喜欢电影。多伦多是一个非常适合伴着电影成长的地方，尤其是多伦多。我们有那么多精彩的二轮影院，它们都是连在一起的。所以你只要有一张通票，就可以去布鲁尔电影院，
you go out to the beaches, all these different places. And I saw the best movies projected with real popcorn, with real butter for 15 years, you know. And I went three times a week. What about your kids? Do they share the same kind of passion? 100%. What about for show biz?
可以去海滩区，去所有这些不同的地方。我看过十五年投影最好的电影，吃着真正的爆米花，涂着真正的黄油，你知道的。我一周去三次。那你呢，你的孩子？他们也有同样的激情吗？百分之百。那他们对娱乐圈呢？
My wife Kelly is like, I hope not. And I'm like, it's gonna be what it's gonna be. And she ultimately is that way too. But, you know, they are, as I am, made of, you know, 2% water and 99% ham. So I think it's likely gonna happen. Do they get what you've done? Do they give it up?
我妻子凯利说：“我希望不要。”而我说：“该来的总会来。”她最终其实也是这么想的。但是，你知道的，他们和我一样，是由2%的水和99%的火腿（表演欲）组成的。所以我觉得这很有可能会发生。他们懂你做过的事吗？他们会拿这个开玩笑吗？
Do they understand your talent and your accomplishments? They do, but they also can torture me with it, which is fantastic. My youngest is Paulina. She's very, very smart. And I'll be like, okay, you gotta go to bed now. She goes, you're bowling, right? What?
他们懂，但他们也会用这个来折磨我，这太棒了。我最小的孩子是保利娜。她非常非常聪明。我会说：“好了，你现在该上床睡觉了。”她说：“你在打保龄球吗，对吧？”什么？
You're bowling. And then she reached back. I wrote a book about Canada and she said, and this book is boring. Throw it on the ground. And I'm like, well, there are parts of it that might be a bit of a polemic, but on the whole, and then I'm like, yeah, she's fine.
你在打保龄球。然后她往后一靠——我写过一本关于加拿大的书，她说：“这本书太无聊了。把它扔到地上。”我就想：“好吧，有些部分可能有点争议，但总的来说——”然后我又想：“好吧，她挺逗的。”
What am I doing? You know, Mike, if I'm lucky enough to get stopped and somebody say something nice, they either bring up Well and Grace or Cat in the Hat. And that was one of the highlights of my career. It was working with you on that movie. It was, I watched you work and construct scenes. I'll never forget that time and you called me in
我在干什么呢？你知道的，迈克，如果我有幸在街上被认出来，有人对我说些好话，他们要么会提起《威尔与格蕾丝》，要么就是《戴帽子的猫》。那是我职业生涯的亮点之一。那是和你在那部电影中合作。我看着你工作并构建场景。我永远不会忘记那次你把我叫过去，
and was it Dana or somebody else? And you asked us to come up with fixes for jokes. And I was like, Mike Myers is asking me to come up with jokes. It was really, really impressive to see how hard you work and to what lengths you'll go to make something great. It was, and it's something I stole and I still think about.
那是达娜还是别的什么人？你让我们来为笑话想一些修改方案。当时我就想：“迈克·迈尔斯竟然让我来想笑话。”看你工作有多努力，为了把事情做到最好你会付出多大的努力，这真的、真的很让人印象深刻。那是真的，而且那是我偷师学艺的方法，到现在我还在回想。
Oh, I appreciate that. Yeah, I think it comes from, I never thought it would happen. And I don't want to blow it, you know what I mean? And so you just, and also too, just, you know, I grew up very working class, you have to work. I never thought anyone was gonna hire me for anything. You know what I mean?
哦，我很感激这一点。是的，我觉得这源于我从来没想过这种事会发生。我不想搞砸它，你知道我的意思吗？所以你就会一直——而且还有，你知道的，我出身于工人阶级家庭，你必须努力工作。我从没想过会有人雇我做任何事，你知道我的意思吗？
That's why I wrote so much of Saturday Night Live because I didn't think anybody would necessarily write for me, why would they, you know? Well, talk about that because I think that it's a very relatable thing for anybody in any industry at any point in life. When you want something really badly and you see that it's actually approaching
这就是为什么我为《周六夜现场》写了那么多剧本，因为我当时觉得不会有人专门为我写剧本，他们凭什么要这么做呢，你知道吗？聊聊这个吧，因为我觉得对于任何行业、生活在任何阶段的任何人来说，这都是一种极具共鸣的事情。当你非常渴望得到某样东西，看到它正在向你走来，
and then actually maybe you're even in it and the success is there. Everybody comes to the point of like, should I ask for help here to either solidify it or make it even better? Or should I hold on to it and make sure nobody screws it up for me? Like there's always that kind of push-pull
然后甚至可能你已经身处其中，成功就在眼前。每个人都会面临这样一个时刻：我是应该在这里寻求帮助来巩固它，甚至让它变得更好？还是应该紧紧抓牢它，确保没有人会把它搞砸？就像那种推拉扯皮永远都在，
about whether you have the courage to ask for and incorporate help or whether you're just going to kind of say, no, I got here without anybody else and I need to stay by myself and at the exclusion of all these other talented people around me, I think that's something that everybody always goes through in any industry
关于你是否有勇气寻求并融入他人的帮助，还是打算说：“不，我没有靠任何人就走到了这里，我需要孤军奋战，把周围所有这些才华横溢的人都排挤在外。”我觉得这是每个人在任何行业、
at any point in life. How did you go through that? It sounds like you did take on other voices. I think, you know, so when you guys have this show, I'm so envious of your camaraderie, which I love because I started with an improv troupe and I'm like the camaraderie, I would like to have a group of people that I have
人生的任何阶段都会经历的事情。你是怎么经历这一切的？听起来你确实接纳了其他的意见。我想，你知道的，当你们有这个节目时，我非常嫉妒你们之间的情谊，我太喜欢了，因为我是一开始从一个即兴剧团出来的，我就想：“这种情谊正是我想要的，我希望能有一群人……”
but it's always just ended up that I, I'm writing my own thing and doing my own thing but I would love to be part of a larger ensemble which is ultimately what my training was. You know what I mean? It just hadn't worked out that way. I think it is just kind of, I just, I feel so honored to be non-Saharan live.
但结果往往是我一直在写我自己的东西，做我自己的事情。不过我真的很想成为一个更大集体的一部分，这本来也是我受到的训练的方向。你知道我的意思吗？只是事情没有那样发展罢了。我只是觉得，能加入《周六夜现场》我感到无比荣幸。
I can't believe it. Second city can't believe it. To make comedies that I thought, I better honor it by working hard, you know? Right. But you do collaborate in a leadership role though but you do collaborate on, you move from sort of collaboration to collaboration.
我简直不敢相信。第二城剧团也让我难以置信。为了向那些我认为很棒的喜剧致敬，我最好通过努力工作来回报，你知道的吗？没错。不过你在一个领导角色中确实也在进行合作，你不断地从一种合作走向另一种合作。
Yeah? Well, I think it's best available idea. Like if you have a data Carvey and he has a funny idea, you'd be an asshole not to go, what was that Dana? Hold on, Dana what? You know what I mean? Yeah, that's what you did on Cat in the Hat.
是吗？嗯，我觉得这取决于采用最好的可用创意。比如，如果你有达纳·卡维，他有一个搞笑的点子，如果你不理他：“刚才那个是什么，达纳？等等，达纳什么？”那你就是个混蛋。你知道我的意思吗？是的，你在《戴帽子的猫》里就是这么做的。
That's what you, we sat down on the floor, you had all the scenes out and you were talking about each one. You're like, just let everybody chime in and figure this out to make the best, you know, the best thing you can make. I was really cool. It has to be best available idea
就是这样，我们坐在地板上，你把所有的场景都摆出来，然后讨论每一个场景。你说：“让每个人都出谋划策，把这个东西弄好，做出你能做出的最好的东西。”这真的很酷。必须采用最好的创意，
and it doesn't matter who says it. Like it just, it has to be, you know, stone soup. We all have to put our ingredients into the pot. That's right. I'm assuming your Netflix thing was such a specific project that you wrote as you said and then you bring in, and then you didn't direct it. You bring in a director
而谁说出来的并不重要。这就好比是“石头汤”。我们都必须把自己的食材放进锅里。没错。我猜你在网飞（Netflix）的项目是一个非常具体的项目，正如你所说，是你自己写的，然后你引入了——而且你没有自己导演。你引入了一位导演，
and that position obviously has a ton of influence over what the audience eventually sees, bringing it off the paper and onto a visual medium. Was that collaboration exciting and fulfilling for you? Thrilling, yeah. Yeah, thrilling because he thinks in pictures, Tim Kirkby. And he's kind of, he's an eccentric English guy. He's an eccentric, I think he's a genius.
这个职位显然对观众最终看到的内容有着巨大的影响力，把纸面上的东西搬到了视觉媒介上。这种合作对你来说是激动人心且充实的吗？非常激动，是的。是的，非常激动，因为蒂姆·柯比是用画面思考的人。他有点像，他是一个古怪的英国人。他很古怪，我觉得他是个天才。
And the world of the Pentavirid is very, very cinematic. It's very, we had a fantastic production designer, Simon Rodgers, and it's, the production design is as much an offering. It's, you know, like I said, it's like the original prisoner and the Da Vinci code had a baby, you know, and it's, I got to play very, very different characters,
而且“五人秘社”的世界非常非常具有电影感。非常棒，我们有一位出色的美术指导西蒙·罗杰斯，而且美术设计本身就是一种极大的贡献。这就好比——正如我所说的——是原版的《密谍》和《达·芬奇密码》生了个孩子，你知道的，而且我得以饰演非常非常不同的角色，
which is awesome. I got to play a very, very old English guy, kind of like the very old English person like that. And I got to play a Canadian newscaster, which is the sort of like, you know, here we are at the sportsman show. There's plenty of things to do, whether you're like skeet shooting or fly fishing.
这太棒了。我饰演了一个非常非常老的英国老头，有点像那种老派的英国人。我还饰演了一个加拿大新闻主播，那种风格就像是：“各位，我们现在在户外运动展现场。这里有很多活动，无论你喜欢飞碟射击还是飞蝇钓鱼。”
Over there's a thousand pound bowl, made entirely out of butter. The local news guy. CHCH TV 11. Yeah, CHCH, Hamilton, Ontario. Well, the tiger cats have had a fantastic season. This year, that same song. You know, whenever I get to Canadian,
那边是一头重达一千磅、完全由黄油雕成的公牛。当地新闻播音员。CHCH电视台11台。是的，CHCH，安大略省汉密尔顿。嗯，老虎猫队度过了一个梦幻般的赛季。今年，又是那首歌。你知道的，每当我模仿加拿大人时，
my Jason will often go, he'll turn me and go, oh, is that right? Hey, like when my Canadian comes out and he'll do it. Oh God, but then when you, when you get into it, and you're all just, ah, fuck there, bud. Oh, fuck, we got a real, yeah. Buddy of mine. Everything's buddy of mine.
我的杰森经常会转过身来对我说：“哦，是吗？嘿——”就像当我的加拿大口音冒出来时，他就会学。哦天哪，但是当你真正进入状态，大家都在说：“哦，操，伙计。”哦，操，我们有个真正的，是的。我哥们儿。每句话都是我哥们儿。
Buddy of mine, where's telling me. I paid for those Aerosmith tickets in snows, snow tires. My dad, my dad, any day that it's sunny, he's from Winnipeg. So any day that it's kind of over, he'll say above, he'll go, it was a hundred above today. I'm like, well, obviously it wasn't a hundred below. So you can just say a hundred. And cause everything's above or below zero, right?
我哥们儿刚才跟我说。我用雪地胎换了那些史密斯飞船乐队的门票。我爸，我爸，只要是个大晴天——他是从温尼伯来的——所以只要天气稍微有点放晴，他就会用“以上”（above）这个词，他会说：“今天气温有一百度以上。”我就想：“嗯，显然不可能有一百度以下。”所以你直接说一百度就行了。因为所有温度要么在零上要么在零下，对吧？
And but anything that's above zero, he'll go, gosh, it's a honey of a day, eh, Willie? He's so happy for good weather. Wait, Mike, that you, that, well, you know, it's amazing to me like that you can just manipulate your voice to do so many different people. Do you like, do you like watch a commercial or a movie or a person at the store and go,
但是只要是零度以上的任何温度，他就会说：“天哪，威利，今天真是个好天气啊！”他对好天气太高兴了。等等，迈克，你——嗯，你知道的，我最惊奇的是你可以随心所欲地变换你的声音来模仿那么多人。你是不是会在看广告、电影或者在商店看到某个人时就会想：
I got to work on that. That's really interesting. I do. So on, with gold member, there was a show on HBO called Real Sex. Oh yeah. And it was this guy who had the, a born, a sex born, sex barn, right?
“我得研究一下这个。这太有意思了。”我确实会。所以在拍《黄金会员》时，HBO上有一个节目叫《真实性爱》。哦，是的。里面有个家伙经营着一个，一个色情农场，色情农场，对吧？
And it's a three-quarter replica of the red light district of Amsterdam. And over there's the Chinese fuck swing. And over there is the room that we keep the towels for the splooge. And over there's where we, and it's like, so that's where a gold member came from. That's amazing.
那是阿姆斯特丹红灯区四分之三比例的复制品。“那边是中国人的操逼秋千。那边是用来放洗‘精’巾的毛巾的房间。那边是我们……”就像这样，黄金会员就是这么来的。这太神了。
Episode 22 of Real Sex. By the way, one of the great movie titles, gold member. What was the name of the film that you did where you played the Scottish guy with the size of his head? Oh, so I married an exporter. Oh fuck, that was funny. God damn it.
《真实性爱》第22集。顺便说一句，这是最棒的电影片名之一：《黄金会员》。你演的那个扮演苏格兰人的电影叫什么名字，就是头特别大的那个？哦，《爱抱丸的女人》（So I Married an Axe Murderer）。哦，操，那部电影太搞笑了。真他妈的。
Which is where the pentaverate comes from. How so? Because the secret organization that he talked about is called the pentaverate. And so I've made the pentaverate, the secret organization that he talked about. Oh, that's cool. When you go to Scotland,
也就是“五人秘社”这个概念的来源。怎么说呢？因为他在片中谈到的那个秘密组织就叫“五人秘社”。所以我就把他在片中谈到的那个秘密组织拍成了《五人秘社》。哦，太酷了。当你去苏格兰，
or when you encounter Scottish people, what is their reaction? Are they, are you like a Scottish hero? I, yes. To be honest with you, it's been lovely. I was there with Higgins for New Year's Eve, because New Year's Eve is big in Edinburgh, a Hoogmini, and it's giant.
或者当你遇到苏格兰人时，他们的反应是什么？你是他们的苏格兰英雄吗？我是的。说实话，这真的很可爱。我和希金斯一起在那里过跨年夜，因为跨年夜在爱丁堡非常盛大，也就是霍格马内节，规模极其宏大。
And so a security guy was attached to us, and he went, Mike, I've got an idea for a second. And I thought, well, we actually did a second one. A second so I married an exporter. Yeah, okay. And he goes, okay, the sun's all grown up now. And he did the whole, he acted it out, and it was a really great idea, to be honest.
当时有一个安保人员跟着我们，他对我说：“迈克，我有个拍续集的点子。”我想，我们其实真的拍过续集吗？《爱抱丸的女人》的续集。好吧，行。他说：“好吧，那个儿子现在长大了。”然后他把整个故事演了出来，说实话，那真的是个很棒的点子。
It had a beginning, middle, and end. There's a character arc. I love, by the way, I love that you said, and it was actually a pretty good idea. It was, it was a good idea. Wait, how did you have two parents from Scotland at, oh, Liverpool. No, from Liverpool.
它有头有尾。有完整的人物弧光。顺便说一句，我太喜欢你刚才说的那句“而且其实是个相当不错的点子”了。那确实是个好点子。等等，你的父母怎么会有苏格兰口音的？哦，利物浦。不，来自利物浦。
They're from Liverpool, but in Canada, every soccer coach and many cops are from Scotland. Is that right? So it's just, you're sort of issued a Scottish accent if you're in Canadian comedy. When you were a kid, did you have a little bit of an accent living in it, and then get rid of it, or? No, but I had weird words, it's just weird expressions.
他们来自利物浦，但在加拿大，每个足球教练和很多警察都是苏格兰人。是吗？所以如果你在加拿大的喜剧界混，你基本上就自带苏格兰口音了。你小时候在加拿大生活时，说话也带点口音，后来才改掉的吗？不，但我会用一些奇怪的词，就是一些奇怪的表达。
Like my brother was driving a car, learning to drive, and my dad said, all right, let the dog see the rabbit. And my brother was like, what? Let the bloody dog see the bloody rabbit. Right, which meant pull out to make a left so people know you're making a left. Let the bloody dog see the bloody rabbit.
比如我哥哥在学开车，我爸说：“好了，让狗看见兔子（let the dog see the rabbit）。”我哥就问：“什么？”“让那该死的狗看见那该死的兔子！”对吧，意思就是把车开出去准备左转，好让别人知道你要左转。让那该死的狗看见那该死的兔子！
What dog? What rabbit? So my brother just got out of the car in the middle of, Don Mills Avenue just got out of this giant thoroughfare in Toronto. That's hilarious. I never knew what they're saying, but they had a famous accent, you know,
什么狗？什么兔子？结果我哥直接把车停在多米尔斯大道中间，直接从多伦多这条交通要道上弃车而去了。太搞笑了。我从来不知道他们在说什么，但他们有一种著名的口音，你知道的，
because Liverpool and the Beatles, their fame is famous, you know, and so people would knock on the door and go, is Mike in? Knowing I wasn't in, and my dad said, oh, no, he's kicking about with this other fellow actually. And they'd say, all right, say it. And my dad would go, I want to hold your hand. And they go, great, cool.
因为利物浦和披头士乐队，他们的名气太响了，你知道的，所以人们会敲门问：“迈克在吗？”明知我不在，我爸就会说：“哦，没有，其实他正和另一个家伙在外面鬼混呢。”他们就会说：“好吧，说一句来听听。”我爸就会说：“我想握住你的手（I want to hold your hand）。”他们就会说：“太棒了，真酷。”
Oh, really? I think when your parents have an accent, you get better accents. For sure, for sure. Yeah. So, Mike, you didn't direct the pentaverate, but do you see yourself, after this experience, because you've created and you've, you know,
哦，真的吗？我觉得当你的父母有口音时，你模仿口音的能力就会更好。确实，确实。是的。所以，迈克，你没有导演《五人秘社》，但在经历了这次经历之后——因为你参与了创作，而且你知道的，
you're in effect, I imagine, show running, and you know what it's like, and you did direct a documentary, but do you see, is the next step going to be for you to direct yourself in one of these comedies where you do something different, either playing lots of characters or bringing in a new character that we've never seen before? Is that something that you're kind of working towards?
实际上，我想象你就像是在担任剧集统筹（showrunner），你深知那是怎么回事，而且你确实导演过一部纪录片——你觉得下一步会是自己执导自己出演的某部喜剧吗？在片中尝试不同的东西，比如一人分饰多角，或者引入一个我们从未见过的新角色？这会是你正在努力的方向吗？
I might. I think that, you know, when they say a lawyer defends himself, he is a fool for a client, you know what I mean? There's a little bit, I love it when somebody else agrees and adds, if you will, and something that you would never have thought of. And that's what my experience with Tim Kirkby was,
我可能会。我觉得，就像他们说的，一个为自己辩护的律师，他的客户是个傻瓜，你知道我的意思吗？这其中有点道理，我非常喜欢当另一个人同意并加以补充，或者说，加入一些你永远想不到的东西。这就是我和蒂姆·柯比合作时的体验，
is he had a big hand in shaping where the series went, you know what I mean? So I may have created it, but where it went, Tim Kirkby had a big hand in, and I also worked a little bit with Michael McCullers on it, who I was the co-writer of Austin Powers 2 and Austin Powers 3, and I love working with him. He's really funny and very, very smart,
他在塑造剧集走向方面发挥了巨大的作用，你知道我的意思吗？所以可能是我创造了它，但它最终走向何方，蒂姆·柯比起到了很大的作用，而且我还和迈克尔·麦库勒斯一起合作过，他是《王牌大贱谍2》和《王牌大贱谍3》的联合编剧，我非常喜欢和他合作。他真的非常搞笑而且极其聪明，
and I think I could direct myself, I think I could direct other things too, which I'd very much be interested in doing. Stuff that you're not in. Yeah, something I'm not in. I have such, when I go to the theater in New York, I get a stomach ache before the show because I want the actors to have a good show,
我觉得我可以导演自己，我觉得我也能导演其他作品，我对这非常感兴趣。不是由你出演的作品。是的，没有我出演的作品。每当我去纽约看戏剧时，演出开始前我都会胃痛，因为我希望演员们能有一场精彩的演出，
you know what I mean? Yeah. And I just went and saw Hamilton with my 10-year-old son, which was fantastic. But he's like, are you okay? I go, I'm nervous, I'm nervous. He goes, you know, you're not in the show. And I'm like, I know, but I want them to have a good show.
你知道我的意思吗？是的。我刚刚和我10岁儿子一起去看《汉密尔顿》，棒极了。但他问我：“你没事吧？”我说：“我很紧张，我很紧张。”他说：“你知道你没在台上演吧。”我说：“我知道，但我就是希望他们能有一场精彩的演出。”
You're like, I hope this worldwide phenomenon is good. Yes, I hope this much awarded, universally praised offering has a good show. Mike, are you good, do you have any plans to make the great Canadian movie, like the John A. McDonald's story, or the Diefenbaker, or? The Tim Horton story.
你的心态就像是：“我希望这个全球轰动现象能演好。”是的，我希望这个备受赞誉、广受好评的作品能有一场精彩的演出。迈克，你有没有计划拍一部伟大的加拿大电影？比如约翰·A·麦克唐纳的故事，或者迪芬贝克的传记？蒂姆·霍顿的故事。
I did think about playing Trudeau, the senior, Pierre Elliott Trudeau, because I think I could actually do it, to be honest. I don't doubt it. But, you know, there is a Canadian movie I'd like to do. I want it, because there is a movement in Canada right now, which my friend, Dave McKenzie, who's a comedy writer up in Canada, calls Cinema Bleak,
我确实考虑过扮演老特鲁多，皮埃尔·埃利奥特·特鲁多，因为我觉得我真的能演好，说实话。我对此毫不怀疑。但是，你知道的，确实有一部加拿大电影我想拍。我想要拍，因为加拿大现在有一种潮流，我一个在加拿大做喜剧编剧的朋友戴夫·麦肯齐称之为“阴郁电影”（Cinema Bleak），
where it's, you know, the children are killed in a bus that goes into the ice breaks, that the school bus goes in, most of the kids die. You know, it's all the, it's very, very... Canada can run quite morbid. Every story is, did you hear about that guy? He died, eh? In Canada.
就是那种，孩子们坐的校车冲进冰面破裂的湖里，大多数孩子都淹死了。你知道的，全是这种题材，非常非常……加拿大人总是能把事情搞得很 morbid（病态阴暗）。每个故事都是：“你听说那个家伙了吗？他死了，诶？”在加拿大。
Yeah, he died in front of his kids, eh? Yeah, he died. And then the kids died, eh? In front of different kids, yeah. Every story I get from my friends in Canada. Horrible, man. It's true. Mike, do you remember, for a while,
“对，他在他孩子面前死了，诶？”“对，他死了。”“然后孩子们也死了，诶？”“在另一群孩子面前，对。”我从加拿大朋友那里听到的每个故事都是这样。太可怕了，老兄。真的。迈克，你还记得吗，有一段时间，
there at Don Sherry on Coach's Corner, it'd be like, okay, we had a hell of a period between the Leafs and the Capitals here, and Don would go, we did. But first, we're gonna go, 12 people died. They fell off a cliff into a lake this morning. And let's put these, and then he'd start crying. And then they'd go to commercial.
唐·谢里在《教练角》节目里，会说：“好了，枫叶队和首都队之间经历了一场激烈的比赛，唐会说：‘确实很激烈。但首先，我们要插播一条：有12人死了。他们今天早上从悬崖掉进了一个湖里。让我们把这些……’”然后他就开始哭。然后他们就进广告。
They'd put these beautiful Canadians up there. And you're like, fuck, man, I know I read that too, but what the hell is going on? I don't wanna... On Coach's Corner, and you're sitting there going, I'd like to know what the latest trades are. They just changed the rule, and let's know what Don Sherry has to say
他们把这些美丽的加拿大人照片放出来，然后你会想：“操，老兄，我知道我也看过那条新闻，但这到底是怎么回事？我不想……”在《教练角》节目里，你坐在那里心想：“我想知道最新的球员交易是什么。他们刚改了规则，让我们听听唐·谢里对新规则修改有什么看法。”
about the new rule change. Gullies should be able to go behind the net and play the puck, right? But first, I wanna go to Kamloops, four kids. Died of a disease that doesn't even have a name. A dad in Timmins walked out into the woods, and he never came back. Never came back, but he did come back eventually,
“守门员应该能够绕到球门后面去处理冰球，对吧？但首先，我要去坎卢普斯，有四个孩子死于一种连名字都没有的疾病。蒂明斯的某个爸爸走进了树林，就再也没有回来。再也没有回来，但最终他还是回来了，不过他已经变得面目全非。”好吧，迈克，我们占用你太多时间了，老兄。我真的为你的新剧感到兴奋。说实话，我太高兴你回归了，而且你还在演大量的角色。这太让人兴奋了。谢谢你们，伙计们。我能说这段经历有多么美好吗？
but he was changed in an indecipherable way. Well, Mike, we've taken up too much of your time, man. I'm so excited for your show. Honestly, I'm so excited you're back, and you're just doing tons of characters. That's so exciting. Thank you, guys. Can I just say what a lovely experience this has been?
你们对我的赞誉有加。哦，老兄。再聊三个小时我都嫌不够。我都不知道该说什么好了。好吧，你是个超级天才。你是个伟大的加拿大人。很长一段时间以来，你一直都是我的灵感源泉，谢谢你抽出时间加入我们，老兄。
You've been most complimentary. Oh, pal. It's easy to do this for three more hours. I don't even know what to say. Well, you're a mega talent. You're a great Canadian. You've been an inspiration to me for a long time, and thank you for taking the time to join us, man.
哪里哪里。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢你，迈克·迈尔斯。保重，再见，迈克。回头见。拜拜。拜拜。再见。
Not at all. Thank you, guys. Thank you, Mike Myers. Cheers, bye, Mike. See you later. Bye, bye. Bye, bye. See you.
那个人简直是个宝藏。是两个国家的宝藏，不只是一个。你说得对。他是两个国家的宝藏。他对我的影响太大了。我的意思是，我以前经常看《周六夜现场》，当时我就想：“天哪，他……”我觉得，正如你们几集前在聊《周六夜现场》时提到的那样——
That man is quite a treasure. Treasure to two countries, not just one. You're right. He's a treasure to two countries. He was such a big influence on me. I mean, when I watched Saturday Night Live all the time, I was like, my God, he's, there's, I think, well, you said it a few times,
或者可能当时有那档节目的嘉宾来过——他们现在真的不怎么演那么多角色了，而他是真正能够一个接一个、一个接一个地塑造各种各样角色的最后几位伟大的喜剧演员之一，而且他们都截然不同。哦，我们甚至还没聊到“咖啡谈话”呢。对啊，没错，没错。
a few episodes ago where we were talking about Saturday Night Live, or maybe somebody was on from there, and how they don't really do as many character stuff, and he was one of the great last ones to really just like roll out character after character after character, and they were all so different. Oh, we didn't even get into the coffee talk. Yeah, right, right.
还有赛门，那个小孩，“好吧，你知道的，我的名字叫赛门，看，我在画画。”哦天哪。我还记得那个。太疯狂了。好吧，还有好几个，显然。而且我喜欢讲故事。
And Simon, the kid who was, you know, well, you know, my name is Simon, look, I'm drawing. Oh my God. I remember that. That's so crazy. Well, there's a few, I mean, obviously. And I like to tell a story.
是的，所有经历过那里的人都才华横溢，但只有极少数人能够——或者说拥有那种戏路，能够完美驾驭那么多不同种类的笑料、那么多不同种类的角色，他们甚至可以反串女性角色，然后信手拈来，真的太鼓舞人心了。
Yeah, everyone that goes through there is so incredibly talented, but there are just a few that were able to, well, but had the range to just nail so many different kinds of funny, so many different kinds of characters, and they could play a character of another gender even, and just like go, it was really inspirational
以至于当他们离开那个环境时会让人感到沮丧，因为再也没有其他地方能让你在一个半小时内做完所有这些不同的事情了。现在听起来，他即将在网飞推出的这部新剧里一人分饰七角，似乎正好满足了这一点，谢天谢地。
to the point where it's depressing when they leave that environment because no other place will allow you to do all those different things in an hour and a half. Now, it sounds like his seven characters with this thing on Netflix coming up is something that kind of, you know, checks that box, thank God.
但我真的很怀念他身上的那种特质。对啊，你太怀念了。是的，他对这些角色和创作有着无法餍足的驱动力，我的意思是，你想想看，先是《反斗智多星》，巨大的热门。然后他们拍了电影，他还在节目里，接着拍了第二部，然后他拍了——
But I've missed that with him. Yeah, you miss it so much. Yeah, he must have like an insatiable drive for these characters and doing the, I mean, you think about it, it comes down to Wayne's World, huge hit. Then they make the movie, he's still on the show, they make the second one, he makes,
《爱抱丸的女人》，当时还在节目里。然后他离开，拍了三部《王牌大贱谍》。他做了所有这些事情，就像是一直在连轴转，现在他又在演七个角色。而且，你知道的，感觉他体内仿佛有一个专门为角色运转的引擎，他自己可能都不知道开关在哪里。没有其他人能像他那样，
so I married an axe murderer, still on the show. Then he leaves, then he does three Austin Powers movies. He does all this stuff, like he just keeps it going, and now he's doing seven characters. And, you know, he just, it feels like he has this engine for characters that he probably doesn't even know where the on switch is or where the off switch is. There's no one else like him
无论是在角色数量、产出还是成功度上，都可以这么说，对吧？肖恩，你在琢磨什么买卖呢？因为我看到你的头脑风动了，我看到脑筋在转。我甚至能看到你的耳机底下冒出了一点烟。耳机底下，对。是的，哦不，那是你制造的假烟，对。
as far as the numbers of characters and output and success, I would say, right? Sean, how's your thinking about a buy going? Cause I see your head, I see the wheels. I can actually see a little bit of smoke coming out from underneath the headphones. The headphones, yeah. Yeah, oh no, it's coming from your fake smoke, yeah.
好了。你在说什么呢？对，你知道的，抽烟最重要的一点是，因为过滤嘴太重要了，所以你只要把它放在嘴唇上，千万不要买。买它。买它。买它。
There we go. What are you talking about? Yeah, well, you know, the important thing is with a cigarette, because the filter is so important that you just put it in your lips and gently do not buy. Buy it. Buy it. Buy it.
聪明。什么。聪明。什么。聪明。聪明。
Smart. What. Smart. What. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjurf. SmartLess.
SmartLess由班尼特·巴尔巴科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿尔姆杰夫100%有机手工打造。SmartLess。
Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的下一期节目将在下周发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，也可以现在就在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上抢先收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）或Wondery应用上的Wondery Plus抢先收听并免除广告。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。